the Joe Rogan experience it's a lot
going on at tennis plus nobody gives a
[ __ ] until you're really good you know
like if you're kind of like if you have
a chance how it plays a you know
semi-pro ball for it if you'll get into
the big leagues you know but it you
don't if you like I'm semi pro tennis
player get a [ __ ] job [ __ ] right
what are you doing you playing tennis it
takes a long time I used to know this
dude who was a professional racquetball
player and that was the grind east of
all grinds because when I was 19 I
recognized like oh no this dude done
painted himself into a corner
he's like a world champion it's
something nobody gives a [ __ ] nobody
cares dude nobody cared and people would
like treat him like oh poor guy
like that was part of it it was like
he's awesome but poor guy well I feel
that way when I watch the biathlon oh
yeah vixen [ __ ] or curling her yeah well
curling is don't talk [ __ ] about curling
in Newfoundland if you go up there in
Canada they get [ __ ] angry at you I
don't give a [ __ ] take it man also I
don't care that you replayed the curling
move in slow motion I I didn't miss it
in regular motion you know and there's a
certain sports I don't I think their
skills are not sports like what Adam
races how to racists deal with the fact
that there's so many elite black
athletes what is a Rick because just
looking and [ __ ] how do you see white
superiority in that many you know I've
heard I've heard guys in New York white
guys would always say this about about
I'd hear white dudes in there talk about
black and white athletes like this
they'd be like well he's a brother so
obviously he's gonna be faster and
stronger but this kid over here he's got
heart and he's got smarts and so like
guys apparently got heart getting brain
where is the black guy only has muscle
it was a clear indication that you're
just it was such a race it's kind of way
of delineating you know what's also
delusional because people want to assume
that because someone has physical
attributes they don't have mental
attributes they always want to say that
and sometimes it's true because
sometimes when you have physical
attributes life is easier for you and
you get soft you don't have to work as
hard like one of the more impressive
guys in the UFC for me has always been
Frankie Edgar because that guy is just a
product of hard work he's
knockout puncher he's not the biggest
guys always in small for whatever
division he's in Eddie view small 55 and
he's pretty small at 45 in comparison to
some guys like you know like or take oh
we fought this weekend right you know
Brian's much bigger than I'm taller
longer he's just all heart and will and
toughness and and I love that and I and
I think that's an admirable thing and I
think you can get a lot out of
Washington guy like that but it doesn't
mean that a guy can't have that mindset
and also have some [ __ ] Ray Lewis body
well my cousin was the example of it
yeah
nobody Kobe Bryant saying yeah nobody
works harder and that's why they're and
they they love to win in an almost
psychotic way yeah extreme winners are
that way yeah that whole thing that
extreme winners is why we're here folks
it's why it's so compelling I mean you
you had to have some ungodly resolve to
get through the Mongol era and the
[ __ ] caveman era and think about all
the different [ __ ] that's happened in
between it's just thinking about the
people that colonized this country we
were so far removed from people who
lived here and rode wagons across the
country just two hundred years ago
there's nothing that just happened they
did this study Camille Paglia was
talking about this why were most of the
people that revolutionized the human
condition male like so in other words
the printing press and Einstein and
Copernicus and Galileo and Kepler and
you know all these people that kind of
like you know and and why why so few
women and so a lot of academic circles
will they're the only single variable
answer is that women were kept down by
the patriarchy or whatever it might be
very condescending though if you think
about it because that would suggest that
women didn't find their way through the
cracks some of them did but for the most
part and there's some truth to that but
for the most part there's another really
interesting theory that men have men and
women tend to have two different kinds
of brains we've evolved to have two
different brains because women had to
watch out for children and pay attention
to the minutiae and keep them away from
death whereas men have the kind of brain
that can obsess over just one thing even
if it doesn't really bear any relation
to the material world so they can think
about whether time bends or whether the
relationship between time and matter and
and space you know and they'll just del
to zero in on that problem and obsess
over that problem you have those extreme
winners that literally to the exclusion
of everything else including their
family including you know other people
focus on just one thing but in a lot of
ways thank God we had that aberration
because that is what revolutionizes that
is what changes their little explosions
that make this thing move quicker yeah
they're the combustion inside the engine
that is human civilization every now and
then you get someone that just is an
outlier some Elon Musk characters
drilling holes under Los Angeles and
building [ __ ] power stations from
solar power from people's houses yeah
make it [ __ ] cars ever gonna work
it's never gonna work it's never gonna
work he's like shut up yeah he's just so
much smarter we let him drill under the
city what go ahead you know what you're
doing everybody just lets him do it yeah
he imagine if like a regular person
wanted a drill underneath the cities and
and make tubes and put that's the
dumbest idea ever we're gonna drop down
a car is gonna go on a train and the
trains gonna go really fast with the car
underground shut the [ __ ] up
you
[Applause]